how's it going everybody it's your
friendly neighborhood dave rubin
you normally see me wandering the mean
streets of los angeles
with my dog but today i am
in the swamp i am in
washington dc the most wretched hive
of scum and villainy and i am here
wandering around first off it's a
complete ghost town there are no other
humans here i'm in a zombie movie with
no zombies that's what it feels like
it's like we it has the eerie feeling
of a zombie movie and yet the zombies i
well i guess there's a little sun out so
the zombies aren't coming outside so i'm
basically an i am legend right now
i'm will smith and i need a dog i really
do need a dog there's
there's cracks in the street
plenty of cracks in the street in this
dystopia all right well i am with
another human here
all right we got a thousand people in i
am here good morning ladies and
gentlemen
with my agent slash bodyguard
pre-pubescent
service agent kyle kashuv my secret
service agent
he's keeping me safe on the mean streets
i i will be shocked if you see another
human in this video
there's nobody anywhere kyle lives here
if you don't wear a mask outside you'll
be shot
yeah you know yeah these are the rules
or tank comes up and blasts you off
sometimes you go to jail if you're lucky
there's nobody here
we could run dc you think trump's even
at the white house i feel like we could
just walk in like the door's probably
going
to be taking her seventh nap of the day
in calabasas at the moment oh she's not
here
nobody's here unbelievable you want to
tell the people about your mask problem
yes so kyle's got an issue with masks
you know everyone the mask thing it's
like i walked it i went into an office
and i did have to
put a mask on um i considered robbing
them at gunpoint but then at the last
second i
said that i'll just go to the back my
mask is not as bougie as dave yeah
kyle's got
just this but my issue i've never had
acne as a kid
never never and now it's popping over
everywhere adult acne
that's one of the side effects of this
thing you know what i mean you people
talk about the side effects of kovid
but they're not talks about the side
effects of my face breaking out now
obviously coconut is real it's you know
but you know this is i can't wear makeup
i can't i don't know how to put on
makeup
right so the question is do you want to
shut down the world economy forever
and usher in a new world order and have
acne right at the same time
and then amazon is going to send you the
skin supplies to like fix my face and
now this this is the roundabout
yeah anyway as you can see we have not
seen another human being
there's nobody there's nobody really
dead there's no way there's one woman
across the world who still are in dc are
lobbyists and
they're de facto zombies so it is
zombies
oh wait i'm almost got getting oh
there's a car there's a car with a man
all right very excited to find a place
to eat in like in dc yeah we're trying
to find a place here we're starving
everything's closed a lot of things
boarded up i just like a turkey sandwich
just uh could i get a turkey sandwich a
wrap maybe a salad nothing is open
nothing this thing is open there's
nothing but we're out here
it looks listen i'll take the phone
listen look at this it literally it
looks like every day we're fighting the
good fight out here in dc okay every day
no we can't cross we'll get run over
listen we're here fighting corruption
i'm here fighting skin acne i do a lot
for the people for the american people
people don't respect that people don't
appreciate the full extent my audience
respects it
for what i do for us ah anyway so i'm
i'm in dc
for about 24 hours uh this afternoon
i'm going to the white house hanukkah
party we're going to celebrate eight
crazy nights uh of those pesky jews
surviving the greeks if i post a photo
that looks like champagne
it's not champagne it's water yes yes if
i post
a picture or a video drinking champagne
it most likely is
champagne um so yeah we're heading we're
heading to the white house in a little
bit
um i actually just this morning i was
just sitting having coffee at the
at the trump hotel and i bumped into
judge jeanine who i've done her show a
million times but we'd actually never
met in person
so it's kind of fun when you no no we're
going to a real restaurant if there's a
real restaurant
um but it's fun when you actually meet
these people in real life
you know because i i think for for you
guys too
you just see you see all this how's it
going man how are you
going all right see good we saw real
people we've been trying to find real
people you guys are real human beings
i'm not i'm on periscope right now is
that cool yeah yeah so real
finally we were trying to find real
people in dc we couldn't find any you
guys are real humans
yeah that's awesome not humanoids in any
way yeah real [ __ ] people can you
believe it incredible thank you
so much cool good to meet you guys thank
you all right take it easy
real people real reuben report people
that's what i'm talking about man three
remaining people in dc
we found it all right that was
incredible did you see i i touched the
guy do i have to disinfect my hand now i
probably shouldn't say that publicly
yeah like it was just no i mean now the
fbi and cia are on your ass oh
god this is how dave goes to jail this
is it people
this is it all right so so yeah so i saw
judging in this morning
and it's nice when you see like actual
people i think one of the things
happening right now is
we don't see human beings anymore and if
you do see human boobs
but if they're wearing a hat like this
and we've got glasses like this
now i understand why kylo ren took off
the mask every now and again
you know i'm not there yet on the star
wars episode so i haven't seen it i'm
working up i'm on episode six or five
you didn't watch it watch it let's not
get killed here look at this there's
nobody
anywhere nobody
there's a couple cars i don't know where
they're going they're all fleeing
oh by the way if you see that little
little scar in my forehead
i was going to uh to a rally in los
angeles the other day
to to rail against this woman sheila
cool who's one of the city supervisors
who shut down all the
all the outdoor meals all the outdoor
eating and then she went for an outdoor
meal she literally voted on it this
woman
who makes three hundred thousand dollars
a year to do jack [ __ ]
she voted to close all the outdoor
restaurants and then she went to an
outdoor restaurant because she knew she
had like a 24 hour window
before they all closed down these people
are major hypocrites or there's
something that they know that we don't
like they don't actually believe their
own rules
no none of them no people they're middle
management morons who can't produce so
they want to control other people that
that's it but anyway so i go to this i'm
on the way to the rally
to protest this woman and we got clipped
on the 405
and uh when i pulled over when i pulled
over i whacked my head on the side of
the door telling you because he got into
a fight with gavin newsom and he doesn't
want to say it publicly they had an mma
match
it was pay-per-view i've been thinking
about challenging them
dave won i would challenge newsome or
garcetti to a duel like maybe that's
where this is all headed you know what i
mean
like we'll just have to have public
duels now like good sir
you've closed down all the restaurants
while you're racking up fifteen thousand
dollar
boos bills at french laundry i challenge
you to do
pay for this i would pay for this people
would pay for that
it's the only way anyway i i hope we see
it was nice at least that the only
people we saw knew me
but it where is everybody
like is everyone just stuck at home
my someone said my bodyguard looks high
you're not high i look high
i'm actually not i'm not no no he's not
high
actually you want to know a little
insider information about
us twitter people we're we're like
twitter people we're going to the white
house
kyle forgot socks well not forgot socks
he only had like ankle high socks
so i didn't want to repeat i bought them
like i only had these socks
one size socks the record i was willing
to pay for dave octopus obviously i
generously accepted happy holidays and
uh and i forgot my belt and you can't go
to the white house without a belt
so we went to h m and we got the
fanciest
socks and belts there is nobody here
i mean i'm not when i tell you this i am
not kidding it's completely dead there
is there is not a human
i can literally run around naked in the
street
it's chilly shrinkage but like
there is no buddy here it's unbelievable
yeah oh here's a guy here's there's i
see one man we're about to
pass a man in a little bit he obviously
is a government agent hold on
let me i don't want to speak too loudly
he's obvious this guy's up to no good
hold on hold on he's not wearing a mask
hold on hold on
all right you see him that that was
shady
i mean this is how you destroy the
country you just shut down yeah this is
how you destroy a country i mean
everything
is shut down i love dc by the way you
know i i joke about the swamp and
everything else and politics and
it's all of that but dc
you know so where what part of town are
we in right now we're basically in
capitol hill right
so we're right by the national mall um
so the capitol building is that is that
so that's the capitol building right
there
here we'll we'll we'll walk towards that
i mean there's just nobody here
you can't even go try to get my brother
a tour you can't even go into the senate
unless like you work there
you can't you can't go inside where's
the where's the jefferson memorial i
know it's a little off the
off the beat you know maybe maybe i'll
do like uh something
in a little bit i got i got like two
hours here
uh maybe i'll do something from the
jefferson memorial because i
it's not in the main path that all the
memoirs you know people think
yeah people think of the lincoln
memorial obviously the washington
monument but the jefferson memorial
really is wonderful
and they have some of his writing uh
etched in the wall and it's really
quite amazing do you know what any of
these other buildings are as long as
we're here
government bureaucracy everywhere but
that's here that's the capital so you
can see it
that's the capitol building right there
that's funny someone made a good point
i've got my bodyguard with me but
there's no other people out here
yeah oh there's somebody doing
construction that's good
they're building the underground bunkers
i suppose
all right we're gonna grab some lunch uh
i assume the people you're allowed to
eat is that that's illegal no we'll
figure it out i don't know if you're
actually allowed to eat
inside i feel like i'm in reservoir dogs
right now with this guy look at this
this is mad max all right i'm gonna go
eat something
and then maybe we'll uh we'll wander
over to the jefferson memorial
or something else and i'll try to do
something from the white house later
we'll see we'll see what happens but
anyway man it's weird it's weird this
isn't how people are supposed to live
you're supposed to live free you're
supposed to wander around have a little
risk in life
see other humans oh god
i had to be a radical revolutionary i
just wanted to be a sports center anchor
you know
that's the truth i just wanted to be a
sports center anchor and now i got to
save the republic what a headache
nba now he's doing live in washington dc
trying to save the republic i know i
know
all right guys thanks everybody i'll uh
we'll check in later
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell